how's it going bros my name's Pete ha
I'm here with me oh my god what a tip
sign up for that shut up
today we're gonna play with Elliot I've
never played where Healy okay don't do
this at home because you might die
probably not that you'll be fine but
people in the comics yet here I have a
trained professional that's 40 we are
trained professionals
and are you a child himself we know all
about doing yes I've never done under Oh
Jason right Wow I don't even know how to
do this grab that [ __ ] we're gonna do
youtuber impressions oh you never done
this before
never hit him how's it going big my name
is pitiful oh good it has it going
everyone I've never done this I'm gonna
guess who this is you you get a point
yes okay okay okay is someone here
welcome to your grammar sucks number
5412
what's that forum this is equals 3 ha ha
ha
like that you know to do it no you just
twist it what twisted like a you're
milking a nipple hey uh what's up [ __ ]
here what you boy thank God good you
gonna get pink up [ __ ] yeah you get
what the [ __ ] is that
he always hey God the [ __ ] are you doing
excited filthy right that's filthy hey I
just wanted to bring back jokey blocks
it like everybody had top of the morning
to you laddies this jacksepticeye okay
hello everyone this is Mark okay what's
going on on it is what that Toby Tom
yeah yeah fine intuitive crested fine
it's red oppressive fine it's right
across from red everywhere
oh geez I don't know about that Rick
doesn't sound like a good idea at all
haha it's a pretty good impression is
there a - oh come on Morty we needed to
build a time shift for day when you guys
face for tea would you do won't worry oh
[ __ ] oh Jesus Christ
bees Oh Nicolas Cage I was Nicky longer
please thanks for watching leave a like
if you enjoyed subscribe to many laughs
I like to the description thank you for
having me out goodbye it's better
daughter to get thinkin to helium with
you boys crack oh he's my blood yeah